[Musik]
in den 80er jahren schockiert eine
unheimliche serie von kindermorden die
schweiz 1989 kann die bevölkerung
endlich aufatmen
dieser mann gibt zu vier kinder getötet
zu haben
sein name werner ferrari sein gesicht
brennt sich ein ins kollektive
gedächtnis der schweiz im april 2007
steht der gleiche mann wieder vor
gericht
in einem fall gibt es neue erkenntnisse
wie viele kinder hat werner ferrari
wirklich umgebracht was hat ihn
angetrieben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den namen werner ferrari verbinden paul
und raphaela im hof mit dem traurigsten
moment in ihrem leben dem tod ihrer
tochter fabienne ihre älteste war ein
wunschkind auf dass sie lange gewartet
hatten
fabienne kam am 17 märz 1980 auf die
welt neun jahre später wurde sie opfer
eines brutalen mörders die seit april
mindestens zwei wochen auf dem friedhof
besuchen und ein mensch wo einst bier
ist ist er vergisst man hier
da darf man auch nicht vergessen das war
im jahr geteilt es war die schlacht
was bleibt ist die erinnerung die
erinnerung an das fröhliche kind dass
alle geliebt haben dennis kruppke die
resonanz die sich laut ersten polizei
fabienne mit ihren beiden jüngeren
geschwistern ralf und eliane ein
besonnenes mädchen technik machte
irgendwie vorausahnend war nie sagt ralf
und eliane und nachrichten stören und
der totenkopf und das hat sie vor wochen
vor ihrem tod zeichners und dass die
techniken der polizei und 1700 reise
oder wenigsten etwas ab lädt am samstag
den 26
august 1989 findet im solothurnischen
hägendorf eine große rally statt
am abend ist das ganze dorf auf den
beinen
auch familie immer auf
mit der kampf kann denn ethische
witziger und aktorik und da sind wir
alle zusammen mit einander dass ich das
wort je wochen lässt sich so leicht und
das ist ganz spezielle situationen oder
das ganz speziell sind das nicht gemacht
während im hof sam fisher beizli etwas
essen zieht familien mit einer freundin
durch die rede nach einiger zeit wollen
die mädchen zurück zu den eltern ein
fremder mann mit schnauz und brille
bietet den beiden an sie zu begleiten
sie gehen mit ihm in richtung kirche
beim dorfbrunnen befiehlt der mann
verbands freundin sie solle hier warten
geht mit fabian allein weiter somit
gehört die kraft
negative und ich hatte einfach das ist
einfach die dass wir so das opferlamm
ich stehe mit dem mit die hätte gar
nicht so viel studiert denn nichts
gefühl auf diesem weg geht familien mit
dem vermeintlichen helfer aus dem dorf
weg von der baby weg von den leuten
einen tag später wird der leblose körper
des mädchens am waldrand gefunden
nackt geschändet er wirkt das ist
natürlich so dass titel lang bis man
einigermaßen nach niedersachsen ist also
ich sehe dass weder die tsx ith naja
will mir hat das im prinzip miteinander
live auftritt braucht also unterstützung
erhält das immer alleine weiter geht
will ich mich ein ca das ist das
schicksal und also etwas schlagseite
prinzipien der mensch selber fertig ein
großaufgebot der polizei sucht nach dem
täter
fabians freundin die beim brunnen
zurückgelassen wurde kann den mann
beschreiben
eine spur führt von hägendorf nach olten
[Musik]
die brille die jacke der wohnort seine
einschlägige kriminelle vergangenheit
werner ferrari gerät ins visier der
fahnder
in der siedlung meierhof wohnt der
hilfsarbeiter der 1971 schon einmal ein
kind getötet hat die polizei verhaftet
ihn vier tage nach dem mord an verlieren
die ersten einvernahmen der
kantonspolizei solothurn verlaufen hat
sich dies ändert sich als kurt amsler
ferrari verhört er ist ein erfahrener
wachtmeister mit väterlicher
ausstrahlung der erste warme regen
schüchterner verschlossene in sich
gekehrte außer hinten sortiert der
mensch vor und dagegen aus neue
ablehnend so natürlich auch gegenüber
der polizei ist eine spätere frau sein
wer ist dieser mann
protokolle unterschreibt er mit zwei
unterschiedlichen namen einmal nennt er
sich werner einmal marco radio fro
genannt wird und wir werden der
ferrari-chef aus verschlossen sie
tatsachen vehement abgestritten dass
heute zum beispiel beim letzten prozess
wonach sie habe aber noch nie erlangt
werner ferrari wird 1946 geboren als
vierjähriger kommt er in rümlingen ins
kinderheim
bis dahin hat er bei den großeltern
gelebt die mutter ist bei seiner geburt
erst 18-jährig der bub kommt ungelegen
später nimmt die mutter ihren sohn für
kurze zeit zu sich eine zeit die ferrari
als albtraum beschreibt stiefvater zog
mich an den haaren zum lavabo und ließ
wasser einlaufen dann umklammerte er
mich mit einem arm von hinten an der
hüfte drückte mit der hand meinem kopf
und das wasser
ich versuchte zu schreien und mich
seinen griff zu entziehen
doch er hielt mich fest wie in einem
schraubstock werner ferrari landet
wieder im heim
dort stellt man eine erzieherische
verwahrlosung fest er erinnert sich
meine mutter hat mich nie geküsst er
nicht einmal bei der hand gehalten oder
mich getröstet wenn ich gewarnt habe
ich wurde nur hin und her geschoben wie
ein störendes möglich stück
die mutter heiratet wieder ihr
zwölfjähriger sohn werner muss ins
knaben erziehungsheim ferrari sagt die
vier jahre die ich im schillings reihen
verbringen musste waren die reinste
hölle
die brutale härte und die
gefühllosigkeit mit devito behandelt
unterzogen wurden verstörte mich
zutiefst
[Musik]
der zürcher strafrechtsprofessor
christian schwarzenegger beschäftigt
sich auch mit täterprofilen von
serienmördern geologische untersuchungen
zeigen dass serienmörder in der frühe
kindheit show problemfall sind dass sie
einerseits von den eltern gewollt werden
dass sie auch daran dass sieht aber
häufig auch quälend sind und sich so
stimulieren
auf der andere sieht man häufig
persönlichkeitsstörung wieder eine
persönlichkeitsstörung in
psychiatrischer sinn war brauche die
schuldfähigkeit die kontroll- und stücks
fähigkeit vermindert bei werner ferrari
lautet die psychiatrische diagnose
schätze wie die mit dieser
persönlichkeitsstörung lebt man in
seiner ganz eigenen welt
abgekapselt von der realen welt
mit 16 jahren kommt ferrari aus dem
erziehungsheim er wohnt bei seiner
mutter arbeitet als hilfs angestellter
wird aber schon bald entlassen
er legt brände verübt diebstähle und er
spielt gerne mit kindern
[Musik]
mit 18 jahren wird er in eine
erziehungsanstalt eingewiesen
wenige monate später reist werner
ferrari auf und begeht weitere kleinere
straftaten
[Musik]
als 19 jähriger muss er in die
psychiatrische klinik ein gutachter
beschreibt ferrari als kontakt armen
einzelgänger mit aufgestauten
aggressionen die er durch zerstörerische
handlungen abbauen
er warnt davor dass ferrari 1 pädophiles
sexualverbrechen begehen könnte
20 monate später wird werner ferrari aus
der klinik entlassen
[Musik]
am 6 august 1971 entführt ferrari an
einem dorffest den zehnjährigen daniel
schwaab
[Musik]
der bub soll sich nackt ausziehen
er beginnt zu schreien darauf erwirkt
werner ferrari das kind die leiche
versteckt im wald
kurz darauf wird er verhaftet und
gesteht die tat
der kindermörder wird zu zwölf jahren
zuchthaus verurteilt kommt nach acht
jahren aber bereits wieder frei 1979
nach seiner entlassung aus dem gefängnis
lebt werner ferrari zurückgezogen er
wohnt in kleinen einzimmerwohnungen
zieht oft um führt ein unauffälliges
leben
er fühlt sich zu kindern hingezogen
besonders zu buche
er sucht ihre nähe treibt sich bei
spielplätzen und schulhöfen herum
[Musik]
1980 beginnt eine unheimliche mordserie
quer durch die schweiz werden kinder
getötet oder verschwinden spurlos
das erste opfer rutscht ein mann aus dem
kanton aargau
1982 rebecca bieri aus dem kanton luzern
im gleichen jahr stefan brütsch aus dem
kanton schaffhausen
[Musik]
1983 loredana mancini aus dem aargau
ein halbes jahr später benjamin egli aus
dem kanton zürich
[Musik]
1984 peter roth aus dem toggenburg bis
heute spurlos verschwunden
1985 daniel suter aus dem kanton zürich
drei wochen später verschwindet sarah
aubert song aus dem wallis bis heute
wird sie vermisst 1986 verliert sich die
spur von edith dritten pass aus dem
thurgau und schließlich wird 1987 der
aargauer christian widmer erdrosselt
aufgefunden
wer sucht sich wehrlose kinder als opfer
aus ein serienmörder die bevölkerung ist
schockiert und verängstigt
mit jedem verbrechen steigt der druck
auf die ermittler werner ferrari wird
nicht überprüft
die polizei bildet eine interkantonale
sonderkommission die soko rebecca doch
die suche nach dem oder den mördern
bleibt schwierig es gibt noch keine dna
analyse und keine zentrale täter
datenbank dass sie acht verschiedene
konten betroffen sie und der drastische
system wird halt nicht jede information
gleich schnell glich zielgerichtet vita
das er wird bestimmt besser als damals
den hauptrunde gemacht und polizei
bleibt ja häufiger der fall vor dem
theater das am tatort gstanzl klar werde
dass es unvorsichtig verhalten das zu pc
und dem kindermörder ist es komme die
zeit und respekt yves mugny und bringen
uns einführen ohne dass er ein
entscheidender fehler macht
die polizei holt unterstützung aus
amerika fbi spezialisten sollen helfen
den kindermörder zu finden
was mit glänzend amerikanern ist vor
allem zu lassen
vor der vor der tatorte der fotografien
stammen von den verletzungen und die
richtige züge befragen bei den führungen
und das rest 96 punkte gaben
durchschlagender erfolg geführt
schon wenige tage danach tauchte dann in
einer zeitung die bange frage auf mit
einem aufruf in der sendung aktenzeichen
xy erhofft sich die polizei einen
konkreten hinweis auf den kindermörder
zwei jahre später zeigte sich dass sie
doch berechtigt war
denn gegen 19 uhr verlässt der schüler
unbemerkt diedorf turnhalle
niemand weiss warum niemand weiß was ich
unmittelbar danach zugetragen hat
während in der turnhalle von windisch
das jubiläumsfest auf vollen touren
läuft kommt es auf einer landstraße
zwischen rufe nach und risiken zu einer
beobachtung die im zusammenhang mit
christians verschwinden sicher bedeutsam
ist ein mofafahrer der probleme mit dem
rücklicht hat sieht im scheinwerferlicht
einen mann mit einem etwa zehnjährigen
kind vermutlich christian wittmann mit
seinem mörder
bereits am nächsten tag bestätigt sich
dass auch christian widmer ermordet
worden ist
schon zwei jahre zuvor wurde am gleichen
ort ein totes kind aufgefunden
die polizei vermutet einen serientäter
aufgrund dieser parallelen ergeben sich
verschiedene fragen die mit einiger
wahrscheinlichkeit in beiden mordfällen
auf ein und dieselbe person als täter
abzielen nach müssen stand das ist was
ist der kanton aargau betrifft ich den
namen von renault ferrari eigentlich
erst ganz am schluss vorteile serie ins
spiel
insbesondere nach dem zweitletzten
delikt dass sie stetig vom richtigen mit
mehr wo man in riniken kunde hätte ich
im zusammenhang mit xy film fall war 3d
inhalte gegangen
ganz konkret offen wählen ferrari hütet
das hätte zurückführt dass man der
wählenden ferrari als mögliche
tatverdächtige auf eine sogenannte
schwarze liste gehabt trotzdem 1989
schlägt der täter wieder zu und tötet
fabian im hof im solothurnischen
hägendorf
[Musik]
erst nach diesem ort führt die spur
direkt zu werner ferrari das eigentlich
nicht bedeutet sondern werden ferrari im
vordergrund steht und habe nie bewusst
sie spüren dass armee habe nie versucht
sind da allerdings dass alle großen
anführungszeichen zu verstehen und zu
begreifen was ihm eigentlich passiert
ist der bezirk spielspaß vertrauen zu
mir kommen und das in groß st zudem
gestanden ist führt nach und nach gibt
ferner ferrari mehrere taten zu er
gesteht den mord an benjamin engel an
daniel sutter
und an christian wittmann und er gibt zu
im august 1989 fabian imhof getötet zu
haben
[Musik]
raffaela und paul imhof wohnen bis heute
in hägendorf im selben haus wie vor 18
jahren nur wenige meter von dem ort
entfernt wo ihre tochter umgebracht
wurde
[Musik]
max ist für mich nie infrage wenn es
einfach immer das gefühl man dem nicht
entfliehen das ist einfach das schicksal
war es im bericht
das holte mit deutschland oder die hoden
irgendwo her gewandert
das holt die einfach irgendwo
und genau gleich wie 1994 kommt es zum
ersten prozess der abgebrochen werden
muss werner ferrari wieder ruft am
ersten verhandlungstag alle seine
geständnisse und behauptet er habe nie
ein kind angerührt
außen ist für konnte sich ausgestanden
ist sie für mich und das ganze schuldig
ich also dass ich würde mich ja ja ja
den falschen wörter betroffen
das ist klar hier kein mit fabienne
nieder so dass die orangen im augenblick
sehe werde ich das oder so daniel so
misst aber meine texte sich über zwölf
verschiedene persönlichkeiten sie sind
krank meint wir haben da nichts dazu
sagen mario etzelsberger hat für das
gericht ein gutachten über werner
ferrari erstellt der psychiater hat sich
in vielen sitzungen mit ihm ein genaues
bild machen können es war durchaus
möglich
daraus entstanden ist der herr und
obwohl gar nie gemacht hat das gibt es
nur würde das zu sieben ganz zart zur
ganze kontext unbeherrschtheit irgendwo
ne pause nur wenn es nicht passt heißt
aber nicht dass es nötig ist
also mini druck ist außer mir verzählt
hätte denkt ist und ich habe studiert
das hat zur stunde um die möglichkeit
dass das fomc oesterweg sie sind die
besteht aber ich will jetzt auf relativ
wahrscheinlich aufgrund von der person
ferrari und zum teil von der
nachfolgende behandlung ich stars
vermehrt überraschung hingegen steht für
mich fest dass die ich stand mit stoff
der vorhin begangen wurde sie unter
natürlichen vermieter die straftaten die
frau punkt im zweiten prozess ein halbes
jahr später ist werner ferrari in fünf
fällen angeklagt in den vier fällen die
er früher gestanden hatte und im fall
roth steinmann den er immer bestritt wir
sind damals die geständnisse zustande
gekommen ferrari behauptet er habe unter
massivem druck gestanden
nach dem rückzug der geständnisse darf
das gericht diese nur noch als indizien
verwerten weil weitere klare hinweise
auf ferraris täterschaft fehlen ist die
beweislage dünn
das gericht steht vor einer schwierigen
aufgabe
im selben saal wie der angeklagte sitzt
als einzige betroffene mutter auch
raphael imhof
ich will einfach alles was ich will
nicht einfach vor der siebte klasse 2000
1000 und sage dann bin ich gegangen aber
das hätte ich hatte das aber nie kennen
wenn ich damit schaffte verzockt hatte
da hat sich der abstand nicht kann
da sind wir sie sagen und das ist ein
herz genoss sie das ich schwitze und
rollt und alles wurde gefühl massig sie
unter anderem sie mit jannik schätze
betroffen
die platzkommission mädchen in der
höchster und und oder denkt sie und
scheint sie mir nicht einmal werbung in
der lahme und außer so zeigt dass ich
hoffe es gezielter zu damaliger zeit
tatsächlich opfer und die opfer
angehörige die sind von auch lässig sie
man hat sie nicht informiert
man hat ihnen kann bestandteil hat seine
berater zu recht schwierige situation
sie für die angehörige von todesopfern
das hat sich sehr stark gewandelt mit
dem opfer hilfe gesetz sind verschiedene
maßnahmen treffen wurden um die
situation zu verbessern
nach und hütt beratung über mehr wird
von meiner arbeit oder verarbeiten
begleiteten verfahren
man wird über die eckpunkte
verfahrensschritt informiert man hat
auch anspruch auf opferentschädigung zu
tag und dadurch probiert man die
traumatisierenden erlebnis abschwächen
ein aufwühlender prozess ist zu ende
werden nur ferrari wurde vom partner
bezirksgericht für schuldig befunden
fünf kinder ermordet zu haben
die strafe lebenslänglich zuchthaus ob
schon für alle ist eine geständnisse
widerrufen hatte sah das gericht es als
erwiesen an
dass er der mörder ist die indizien sind
zum teil ziemlich schwach aber seine
geständnisse von damals da hat es
details drin die wirklich nur der täter
wissen konnte eine tat hatte er neben
einem maisfeld begangen dass an jedem
tag gewählt wurde das hat man
kontrolliert da stimmte er hat die
polizei an die tatorte geführt sechs
jahre später die tatorte seien anders
aus im waldstück konnte auf den meter
genau angeben wo das kind gelegenheit
das tote kind das kann fast nur der
mörder wissen sie haben diesen man ja
beobachtet während der zwei prozesstage
in wettingen gestern und vorgestern
wie hat er auf sie gewirkt wie man ihn
gefragt hatte dem ausreichend antwort
gegeben gestern oder gefragt waren sie
denn er hat gesagt so wie ich mich kenne
habe ich so kinder nicht umgebracht das
ist so verschlüsselt oder hat gesagt
wenn man mir sagt dass seit ich im
gefängnis bin keine kinder mehr so
umgebracht wurden dann muss ich ja
annehmen dass ich zwar verschlüsselt und
ganz interessant wenn verlesen wird was
er selber schreibt er scheint viele
briefe an anwälte an ehemalige leidigen
verhört haben dann wird es ganz
interessant der mann kann sehr gut
formulieren war sehr gut was in ihm
vorgeht wenn etwa beschreibt wie er da
in den zehn jahren geliebten habe dann
wieder ein kind angesprochen das kind
wieder umgebracht dabei hat ja nur liebe
von ihm gewollt und sei neben der leiche
gesessen hätte gewarnt nach seiner
mutter gerufen
da wird einem fast ein bisschen
merkwürdig man hat fast mitleid mit dem
man auf der einen seite muss man sehen
was er angerichtet hat welches leid wenn
es denn wahr verursacht
das hat nicht unbedingt auch der
journalist peter holenstein hat sich
intensiv mit werner ferrari
auseinandergesetzt
in seinem buch der unfassbare hat er
sich eingehend mit der frage nach
ferraris motiven beschäftigt
vielschichtig also dass auch es ihm
ziemlich vielschichtig
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen dass sr
formen vor eifersucht sie ist oft die
rind will dir die kindheit kannten
amerikaner obwohl klare beweise fehlen
wird werner ferrari in allen fünf fällen
schuldig gesprochen aber getan nicht
unbedingt vor augen das kgv zur
verantwortlich zuckerwatte und mit
mangelnder oder überhaupt dann überwies
verurteilt worden
da der situation auf einmal stand es
wieder in einem fall hat werner ferrari
nie ein geständnis abgelegt im fall roth
steinmann
das zwölfjährige mädchen aus würenlos
trifft ihren mörder am 16 mai 1980
[Musik]
sie fährt nach der schule mit dem velo
durch den wald als rot nicht nach hause
kommt machen sich ihre eltern sofort auf
die suche
der vater sieht einen mann auf einem
moped den er später als werner ferrari
identifizieren wird
kurz darauf findet er seine tochter
ermordet
mit einem alten teppich bedeckt
[Musik]
im sommer 1980 erhält ruth vater anonym
dieses foto ein bild des angeblichen
mörders seiner tochter der mann auf dem
foto sieht werner ferrari zum
verwechseln ähnlich die ermittler gehen
diesem hinweis aber erst 23 jahre später
nach im jahr 2003 sie lassen den 1983
verstorbenen exhumieren um seine zähne
mit bissspuren auf der leiche von ruth
steinmann zu vergleichen
der wissenschaftliche dienst der
stadtpolizei zürich untersucht das
gebiss des toten sowie die zähne von
werner ferrari also vor allem fand
eigentlich ruf das den exhumierten haben
rasieren unregelmäßige zahnstellung im
unterkiefer
da haben wir sogar ein zahn der stadt
wirklich gott nimmt gerade eigentlich
verehrt den und bim während ferrari
da fällt sofort auf dass er sein
unternehmen hat und nicht hier
die vermessung mit dem 3d streiflicht
gerner ist hoch präzise
roth mörder hat das mädchen gebissen und
damit spuren hinterlassen
[Musik]
die zähne von werner ferrari und das
gebiss des exponierten werden mit der
bisswunde auf der brust des mädchens
verglichen
[Musik]
fixiert so verschieden die dispositionen
dieses 3d modelle mehr hits maßstäblich
die wunden ihnen drucke und jetzt selber
sehr deutlich wie immer zum beispiel das
sei jetzt klar der wunder also praktisch
ins grab
tretet sei wo man sie die wunde stecken
während miteinanders beurteilt und sind
zum schluss hoch dass man der werner
ferrari könnte schade dass er tat es
nicht appliziert hatte
und das muss in engste betrachten wenn
sie das der exhumiert die babys
verursacht hat
werner ferrari verlangt aufgrund dieser
erkenntnisse eine neubeurteilung des
falls am 10 april 2007 steht er deshalb
wieder vor dem bezirksgericht waren im
revisionsprozess wird noch einmal
beurteilt ob er im fall roth steinmann
wirklich täter ist also ein
revisionsprozess wird dann durchgeführt
wenn wir neue beweismittel auftaucht wo
zum zeitpunkt von mehr stur teilen könne
festgestellt werden und gefragt von der
gerechtigkeit dass man normales
verfahren wert wo er begegnet der taxis
also wo neue umstand auftaucht wo ihn
als täter ausschließen
im normalfall hat das auch gravierende
konsequenzen will üblichen wies führt
das dann zum freispruch und zur
freilassung von der person in dem
konkreten fall jetzt ist aber so dass
nur vier andere tat vorgänger sind und
dass deshalb strafmaß wirklich worden
ist
[Musik]
am 11 april 2007 kommt das gericht zum
schluss
es bestehen erhebliche zweifel an
ferraris täterschaft das urteil
freispruch im fall roth steinmann
[Musik]
gerade sind sie nicht zufrieden ist
werner ferrari weil er darauf beharrt in
allen fällen unschuldig zu sein
und weil sich am urteil zuchthaus
lebenslänglich nichts geändert hat
lebenslänglich hervor wie ganz wenige
delikt und bedeutet grundsätzlich dass
personen in freiheit entlassen
aber das gesetz sieht auch vor dass die
person frühestens nach 15 jahren keinen
antrag stellen auf bedingte entlassung
das hat das missverständnis gelang
williams gehör sich politik entwickelt
hat dass man praktisch jeder person wo
lebenslänglich verurteilt diese chance
hat bedingt den slow ein glas werte aber
das ist kein automatismus wie im gesetz
vorgesehen
das neueste psychiatrische gutachten
stellt für ferrari keine gute prognose
er wird wohl den ganzen rest seines
lebens hinter gittern verbringen müssen
doch was ist mit den anderen noch
ungeklärten fällen der 80er jahre
wer ist für das verschwinden dieser
kinder verantwortlich
tragen die verbrechen die handschrift
eines einzigen täters
die polizeiliche arbeitsgruppe soko
rebecca gibt es noch immer und die akten
der ungelösten fälle liegen auch heute
über 20 jahre später noch griffbereit
werden rund 600 seiten dienst bis an die
andere ihnen ins befragung mich dadurch
befragt worden und es positives ergebnis
ergab das heißt mit dem die daten können
dann angewiesen um barcelona ist werner
ferrari in den anderen fällen als täter
auszuschließen
da werden wir uns als crossover aber es
besteht natürlich möglichkeit dass er
unsere daten für die kritiker noch die
frage wo die eventuell nicht angenommen
nur die offene erlebt hat die zusammen
hamburger waren
gibt es noch einen anderen kindermörder
einen der noch frei herumläuft einander
lieben wenn ferrari news die als
münchens erteilte vor der andere serie a
club agadir fragt die städte im ruhm
tatsächlich nach der verhaftung vom wenn
ferrari heimat der schweiz
es verglich das delikt fast täglich
besuchen imhofs das grab von verliehen
für sie steht fest wer ihre tochter
umgebracht hat
doch eine frage bleibt unbeantwortet das
warum das könnt ihr nun eigentlich frage
um das frage den eigentlichen berufen
als warum die zwei antwort nie
[Musik]